Is there a way to turn off the beeped noise emitted through the right machine or laptop?
So the beeped noise is not coming from the laptop, but it is coming from the right machine and also
from the bulb
Is there a way to eliminate it?
No, you can put the machine under the bed. You could put something over it
You just don't want to you want to make sure you're not overheating the machine. That's the only thing you have to be careful about
So you can cover it. We've had some patients put it in a drawer in the bed side stand
Get a lower drawer and it stops the sound
You could put a small pillow over it as long as you have air circulating underneath it
You don't want the machine to overheat as well. So make sure you're checking there
now with the
with
the fire jackhammer amplifier you couldn't put the bulb under the bed
So you're mothling the cell that's really all you can do the frequencies will make a noise just is a byproduct of it that you can't get away from